[Music]
good morning guys so today is the very
first day of 2019 that were filming
we're filming JK party today these last
few days coming back from Hong Kong have
been very difficult they have been
pretty much my little hell on earth
because two days before leaving Hong
Kong I came down with something I don't
know what the heck it was but I got
really sick the last two days I was just
in bed and I missed out on family
bonding time in Hong Kong but I had a
fever I was coughing like crazy
I had crazy phlegm my head was like
about to burst I had such a crazy
headache and then I also felt like a lot
of pressure like sinus pressure and it
was just not fun like I was just
miserable in bed and so those are the
last two days and then the day before we
leave my time of the month happened and
it was like the worst timing ever
because then I was about to get on a 13
hour flight back home so it was not fun
at all and finally when we got back
these last few days I've been trying to
fix my sleeping schedule but it's just
been crazy like I've been waking up at 4
in the morning at 5 in the morning so it
has not been fun these last few days
trying to like react limine I don't know
why I mean I probably because I got sick
and then I think I look a little bit
sick too when we got back so we had to
buy medicine like you look at my
nightstand right now yeah we bought
Isaac some coffee and cold medicine some
ibuprofen and then for me I got this
like nighttime daytime like they cool
nyquil and then these are sleeping pills
I tried them out for the first time last
night and a kind of word not really in
an Advil
but right now I'm already am all dressed
to go to JK party actually really quick
before I leave I wanted to show you guys
what I bought in Hong Kong remember how
I said that I bought a whole bunch of
stuff and I loved it so much and I
wanted to do like a mini haul for you
guys well I don't have time to actually
put the clothes on because I mean I can
head out but I did want to show you all
my clothes because I am taking it as
wardrobe for JK party so first thing is
this cardigan thing that I'm wearing
it's super cute I love it
and then this long-sleeve shirt under
and then and I also taught this shirt
it's so cute you know what I'm so in
love with this out because the material
is incredible and it was so affordable
like Anna and I we kept going crazy on
the stuff that we bought because all
this stuff it's such cute stuff and
amazing quality is so thick like we
can't get this here or at least not in
the places that I shot I cannot get
clothes that are this good quality and
warm and super affordable but yeah I got
this one too it's another long sleeve
and then this one it's like a white
cream color and it has like these like
bat wings things so it's pretty cute and
then I got this one similar cutting it's
like really baggy and loose but it has
like these little lines in the middle
and then that pretty much it I got this
Disney on Hong Kong sweater but you know
it was so annoying
the arms are stupid short like they're
so short it was so frustrating because I
have really long arms and like all the
shirts that I got they fit like this I'm
like come on no one has arms this short
but anyway and then I got this jacket -
it's like trenchcoat thing look how cute
this is
and again amazing quality I love it know
one of my goals for 2019 is to do more
fashion centric type of content for you
guys because a lot of you guys are
always asking me like oh my gosh where'd
you get this so where'd you get that or
I like your son style thank you by the
way but I do want to make more videos
like showing you guys it's in my closet
or where I go shop yeah
like opening up that side of me a little
bit more because I think I've been
fighting it I feel I've always felt like
oh my gosh like Who am I like no one no
one cares about my opinion on fashion
stuff or whatever but I do get an
overwhelming amount of comments from you
guys and I appreciate them so much and
so I'm gonna try to embrace that side of
me a little bit more and show you guys
some more of my fashion side I don't
know I was really excited I want to show
you guys my Hong Kong hole I wish I had
time to actually put them on for you
guys in the model but that would be for
another video for another type of
fashion thing I don't know I'll figure
it out oh yeah okay I really got to go
to my shoot now
bye my honey bunches of oats you look so
tired I was telling them how horrible
his last few days have been for me oh
all right I gotta go hi oh my favorite
thing that I've missed so much hi my
baby hi beautiful hi gorgeous
I have been missing my baby so much I
get so funny because in Hong Kong we
kept seeing a ton of tesla's everywhere
Isaac's like look Longtooth him I mean
in a brand new but still brand-new I
haven't gotten to really enjoy it since
we've been gone as soon as I got it we
went to Hong Kong but I was just about
to tell him that every time I drive this
car it feels like going on a field trip
like I am just so excited to drive it
and be in it and just immerse myself in
it you know it's cool too by having this
car in here this entire garage smells
like a new car - isn't that crazy
like this whole garage smells like
okay I gotta put this boy family holding
I gotta put my shoes on I really gotta
go alright I'm here now take a party and
look look look
who ya has blue hair girl I love it so
much I love this like tone - it's so
good you look great
happy new year happy thank you so much
she took care of her idiot
oh yeah ya know what aren't you
I can't mix them up any this is Maya
where is his oh wait this looks like
this looks like so wait is he okay this
might be Maya she's good
he's chillin she's sending us videos and
my kidney though but then she'll be like
oh this would be like oh look she's so
cute I'm like oh girl look but it's okay
yes specifically for you in West they
may comment it on my on my Instagram
yeah they're like I'll make sure to have
him for us so like I definitely did it
was amazing was so good we had it in
like help yes that's why I heard the
best eight hearts come you couldn't get
Nikki came hi every new year Julian
added something what do we get what did
we get I got lipsticks for everyone this
is a little warmer happy new year
welcome to just kiddin party are you
ready to be tortured I'm ready to be in
Tiff's ball yeah I'm excited yeah you
never done take your party have you
maybe many many years ago I think it was
oh but not reason it and now with the
new cast no the new cast there's a new
cast well we're excited how much Prince
aren't too bad yeah not at all
no I think actually you're in luck
because Michaels here and I think we
might be going easy like the torch I
know but he's the one that liked to
torture us you hate yourself doesn't
mean you need to hate all of us pressure
to love okay so we're all gonna suffer
today then I don't know I didn't plan
anyway I'm just here to have fun
to uh to be a cast member he'll do
whatever we do it I think that's why I
said we're safe because he didn't
planning that's why I got the call sheet
at all you know to see what we're
playing it was like everything I like
the true rise to
yeah oh it's work I mean not work out
thank you I mother so you like my shoes
thanks do you give them to me for my
birthday
you know we're missing Gio in part and
Joe they're not gonna be here this is
the new cast so it's very lonely with
them but it's fun it's a different
environment some new new new group new
energy I love it I love it
everyone don't you alright we finished
the first two videos and now we did a
wardrobe change
no I realized you know how I was telling
you guys that I was really busy this
morning the UPS guys [ __ ] like it's
pretty loud but yeah you know how I was
telling you guys that I was in a rush
this morning and I couldn't wear all
this stuff great he's walking
third time's a charm so you know I was
telling you about I was in a rush this
morning I couldn't wear all this stuff
that I bought for Hong Kong but I just
realized I'm gonna be dressing and
changing until this stuff anyway all day
so I could just show you you see let me
put it down it's all crooked
but yeah I don't know I love these
clothes they're so cute and it's so warm
but I'm actually really hot because the
lights in the studio is really hot and
we did a really active first two games
we're playing charades and stuff so now
I'm like Dan is a little too warm all
right guys it's lunchtime we got to
patil to booklet you know I only ordered
two tacos and look how much food they
give you this is the reason I don't like
eating Chipotle because in my opinion
they give you way too much food which I
know it's something weird to complain
about but I don't like wasting food and
I feel like that always waste food on it
order Chipotle I did it finish my
Cheetos
and another wardrobe change
[Music]
another wardrobe change and like this
shirt
alright we just wrapped JK party for
today how did you like it all right
that's the beauty of Josh I know he kept
screwing us up in the last game it was
so funny what we're seeing he's on it
doesn't even matter he's on his own team
what do you have to say about that Josh
well juice juice for all the other days
though that's how we love you Josh
because you throw things off and it's
just so fun it's super entertaining I
love it yeah it was really fun today or
wrapping up we're gonna head home I
can't wait to see my boys see what Isaac
stand up to today it's so funny because
I'm wearing this outfit and I totally
feel like I look like a mom like those
older moms you know I mean you are I
know I forget that I'm a mom go meet you
it's just so like I had him so young I
forget sometimes it's true he's like
your best friend she totally is my best
friend said to be best friends with you
oh no you're not course he loves me too
okay
no it's so awesome cuz we have
conversations and he's like literally
like right now he's my most favorite
ever cuz he's old enough to understand
and like have really deep conversation
and we're able to really connect
yeah so right now it's online for sure
right now he's like my favorite like my
most favorite stage he's never been into
like older and that so I'm like trying
to hold on you know to like the lab well
little rip upitis like stay because I'm
not he's about like I'm gonna blinking
see my friend you dressed Osama but baby
yung and her daughter is not 21 and they
were they share clothes kind of really
jealous of her teenage pregnancy now
because I wish I had a BFF right a baby
boy but I'm about to go see him see what
he's up to
- oh yeah you're kidding cat - boy
Kiki's scared it who's sick was sick he
needs your all your love right now two
days I know it kidney stones
I prefer man - I know always he has a
hot nurse I got home a bit earlier than
Casey and I think Isaac just got back
from his piano lessons Casey just got
back from buying groceries for dinner so
let's go see it hey baby how was your
day at school it was good yeah yeah
how's your jet lag been pretty bad
pretty bad how is it your party
oh you like the way I'm dressed I looked
nice all the time when we're home we
talked about
just kidding a dog you don't you know I
like you what you faked your hair I
straightened my hair all the time but
now that for home okay it's like this
French look kind of TV you get em all
happy at all nice and dressed up when I
was yeah and then everyone sjk gets the
straight hair tip which I really really
like really well straighten my hair more
for you than at home and I'll dress up
like Lily's dressed up I'll get out of
my sweat I'll get in a comfortable nice
clothes
yeah
[Music]
[Music]